hey guys I'm Ryan right so let's be
crazy today we're checking out a video
from my favorite dudes Key & Peele
it's a video recently released pregame
pump up let's watch this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
just a random sword perfect
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this game I get to that came of your
live when it first started out I was
like okay this is a difficult key and
peele thing where like they start off
doing something and then it turns into a
weird competition but they took it to a
whole other level man that was really
funny like they broke I just love when
these Sprint's out of there and then it
becomes like this total like action
drama that's so funny I love that they
just had a random sword there and he's
like yeah what is that the bill the oh
god that level of build-up is so funny
what I love about the key & peele
sketches is they seem like so genuinely
funny in the sense that that's a good
job they seemed like they were just
talking and they were like you know be
funny and then they just share it and
they're like we should do that it
doesn't seem like they're like writers
in a room sitting around like hmm and
what should we do like I feel like that
does happen though or they just come up
with something really good be like I
need to bring this to the table yeah
really good sketches have such a level
of spontaneity to it and yeah there's
such a energy and flow that you don't
really get from a lot of sketches these
days just for example at the end even
though you know he's clearly you know a
level-10 badassery major he saw has a
dainty little cut yes
and it's just everything everything is
so perfect like to the tee that they do
the escalation level of how everything
builds is so well done I [ __ ] love
heavy yeah they're [ __ ] man they just
know how to like start off funny and
there's keep topping what they're doing
well they work so well together they
just they just bounce off each other and
I know they always outdo themselves my
[ __ ] I didn't see that one is that is
that a real thing you don't like Black
Hawk oh I think we're talking about a
sketch they did no oh I'm like is that
like appropriate to have on TV now that
I don't I don't know see I don't like
like hug never seen it don't know
I thought dancers like bruised and
right now what you talking about about
how your penis is breezy anyway guys
thanks for tuning in if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe you're the
real rejects you can check out elisa on
a list of be crazy you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter and vine
because we can get more product
placement
dwight lee morales
what's up real rejects i love your
videos PS i can't wait for the force
awakens matt force awakens looks great
well Dwight lee Morales what I gotta say
to you my friend is let's see how old
you look based off this I don't know
what kind of proper way to guide you
because I know you guys asked for
shoutouts cuz you're looking for
guidance yeah he's really into anime he
likes South Park to see Sammy sees a
gamer he's a gamer ok so I'm going to
assume you're around dan is like what
late 20s yeah I'm going to assume that
since you're into such childish things
that you are also in your late 20s white
are you are you saying I'm a child -
well you're a girl you have exceptions
oh ok but Dan on the other hand no but
Dwight I think you and Dan would be
great buddies you know you guys can hang
out
you can sit chocolate mochas together
you can also then you know gay marriage
is legal now see Mike want to Jack each
other off - well I'm sorry but he's
already taken so that's it's not it's
not cheating on you if it's with another
guy you say you would still consider GRU
yeah hey baby if I had got jerked off by
a guy would you consider that cheating
thank you
I guess it's a cheating thing don't do
it boy